I suspect that every aid worker in Africa comes to a time in her career...
...when she wants to take all the money for her project,...
...maybe it's a school or a training program, pack it in a suitcase,...
...get on a plane flying over the poorest villages in the country...
...and start throwing that money out the window.
Because to a veteran aid worker, the idea of putting cold, hard cash...
...into the hands of the poorest people on Earth doesn't sound crazy.
It sounds really satisfying.
I had that moment right about the ten-year mark,...
...and luckily, that's also when I learned that this idea actually exists,...
...and it might be just what the aid system needs.
Economists call it an unconditional cash transfer, and it's exactly that.
It's cash given with no strings attached.
Governments in developing countries have been doing this for decades,...
...and it's only now, with more evidence and new technology...
...that it's possible to make this a model for delivering aid.
It's a pretty simple idea, right?
Well, why did I spend a decade doing other stuff for the poor?
Honestly, I believed that I could do more good with money for the poor...
...than the poor could do for themselves.
I held two assumptions: One, that poor people are poor in part...
...because they're uneducated and don't make good choices.
Two, is that we then need people like me to figure out what they need and get it to them.
It turns out, the evidence says otherwise.
In recent years, researchers have been studying what happens when we give poor people cash.
Dozens of studies show across the board...
...that people use cash transfers to improve their own lives.
Pregnant women in Uruguay buy better food and give birth to healthier babies.
Sri Lankan men invest in their businesses.
Researchers who studied our work in Kenya found that people invested in a range of assets...
...from livestock to equipment to home improvements,...
...and they saw increases in income from business and farming one year after the cash was sent.
None of these studies found that people spend more on drinking or smoking...
...or that people work less.
In fact, they work more.
Now, these are all material needs.
In Vietnam, elderly recipients used their cash transfers to pay for coffins.
As someone who wonders if Maslow got it wrong,...
...I find this choice to prioritize spiritual needs deeply humbling.